[Music]
i have this
david bond was he a
becoming anonymous 10 simple internet
privacy hacks
is he pivoting is he trying to pick he
is no he really is that's not even a
joke he's been pivoting into bitcoin
into other videos out of being
did we shame him into pivoting i think
we did and then if he clips this he's
gonna
he's gonna buy a thousand more bots
saying how handsome he is
we made this man change this entire
[ __ ] thing
i believe that's amazing we took out a
pickup artist i love it
let's check them out
[Music]
okay it's pretty cool bro you know what
can you go back to [ __ ] time
is with a gopro strapped you had i
actually i
now now in retrospect i i i respected
you more than
[Music]
yo guys so i got a lot of positive
feedback on my previous video that you
bought
video titled becoming anonymous the
david bond
guide to maximum security and privacy
online
the issue was it was quite long and
quite intense
so i wanted to make a part two thank god
because i was sitting here mike and i
were talking about fair going like is he
going to make a follow-up to his video
yeah i mean these bots are dying to hear
what you have to say next
so this will be my top 10 practical
simple
easy steps so you should hold on so now
he's trying to be a top 10 list youtuber
because he's done a lot of different
things so now this is a top 10 youtuber
cool
that you can take yeah that's right
internet security
hey you got any gum piracy hacks while
you're watching this video
to improve your security and pride he
decided i want a beard
but [ __ ] that mustache hey yeah i don't
need that
uh paul you like the uh the bitcoin cash
huh yeah that's right bitcoin cash yeah
privacy on the internet now i understand
that my i think his real name is stephen
maple
previous video on privacy was very long
and very interesting pointed it out and
now it's bothering me the mustache yeah
he decided i'm gonna have a beard but
not a mustache what are you [ __ ]
chester a arthur
abraham lincoln over here what an
[ __ ]
i wanted to make a shorter more concise
and more practical
top 10 list for you guys i get it but
you also have a beard like those amish
parents from kingpin
and it's really bugging me he really
looks like he's on rump sprint
you go all the way to thailand for rum
spring up digit
i know look i know a lot of you guys
don't need all this privacy and security
you're just a regular guy
but but not you look you're internet
famous david bond
i get it man a lot of you listen a lot
of you [ __ ] losers out there are
gonna stay
losers for life you [ __ ] losers and i
get it
but a guy like me all right a [ __ ]
winner
guys like us we need [ __ ] internet
security not you [ __ ] johnny jerkoff
not you [ __ ] ham and eggers out there
but i still wanted to make a list for
everybody number one is definitely going
to be
delete your linkedin account
well like what if you're in the
corporate world that need one yeah
also linkedin is like the hardest thing
to just publicly view
you have to actually be logged into it
and to see stuff
i am completely baffled that people even
have linkedin accounts you might as well
call it
docsmeusa because that that's candace
owenson's site so shut the [ __ ] up all
right
and no people have linkedin accounts
because in the business world you
actually need one you know
especially if you're in the corporate
world like you know it actually helps
it'll help you get a job
basically is what it is any time that
you study someone getting cancelled
or having internet heat on them the
first place that people look is
linkedin because twitter david did you
know that there's a bunch of people that
work in the corporate environment that
aren't just
dropping n-bombs on twitter all
willy-nilly did you know that
did you know there's a bunch of people
that just go to work and go home and
live a nice quiet private life
cause you're basically just self-doxxing
everything that's important about you
your name your age where you work where
you used to work i mean where
i mean all of that really could be
figured out from a cursory gurkle google
search
college it's ridiculous delete your
linkedin account now
i know some of you think linkedin's
important
i honestly do not understand why because
you don't work in the corporate world
if you work in the corporate world
linkedin is very important
and also the stuff that people post on
link when linkedin is not racist stuff
it's usually like
hey you know i just got a promotion i
got a promotion
i'm an assistant manager now like it's
not it's not
linkedin isn't a site where people are
making [ __ ]
part of [ __ ] hot takes all the time
no it's really not if you're gonna have
a little
besides i mean once you have a facebook
your information's all out there anyway
facebook's way more dangerous than
linkedin
you know people can find out where you
work just from facebook you know
like i have a bunch of friends that all
work together um
they all work at uh they get money at um
hustle every day which i didn't know was
an actual company or a job
i didn't know getting money was a
position and then i didn't know hustle
every day
and they all went to the school of heart
[ __ ] i was gonna make that joke i hate
you
i had another tip i was waiting for you
to shut up and i was gonna say yeah most
of them went to the school of hard docs
same college same job i should have went
to that college i would have job
placement
if you're someone who is in a world
where linkedin is important i guess but
at least make it private at least number
two is gonna be a hard one this one is
my favorite one this is the whole reason
i brought this video to the show number
two i cannot
emphasize this enough if you want
privacy
fun for a lot of you to swallow and that
is delete
your contacts i know
a lot of you are mayor that sounds
what like hell why would you delete your
contacts
i mean i'll admit i'm very very lazy
about putting people into my phone
like i do have a lot of just numbers on
my call log but
oh my god i couldn't imagine if i
deleted all the other ones too just how
confused well my problem is i'm lazy and
i just have like three contacts that
just say lawn guy
so i don't know which one's which david
i mean are you just you just want people
to be
texting like hey what's up what's that
mouth do
i want to i want to feel that wet later
and then it's like hey this is your
mother
like oh [ __ ] and then you know he you
know he might just say yeah i know
like why would you decide could you
imagine deleting all your contacts and
then still trying to cheat on your
girlfriend
how could how hard that would be
so a lot of you are married to your
contacts
because you need to communicate with
people and to
live in the world oh i'm sorry i'm good
at maintaining
interpersonal relationships with people
oh i'm sorry i like to
have friends that we can communicate
with each other
that i don't have to pay well i'm sorry
i don't know about you
[ __ ] losers and all you plebians but
david bond likes to pack a tight
suitcase if you know what i'm saying
you're not a [ __ ] secret agent you're
just a creep with a gopro on your head
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you really you
really this guy really thinks who the
[ __ ] he is
it's enraging i can't delete my contacts
my contact list is so important i've met
you guys before
yeah they're called human [ __ ] beings
she's a human [ __ ] being man but
when did we meet i would remembered i
would have remembered meeting
such an overly confident unaccomplished
creep
and you know what i used to be one the
guy who has to back up his contacts
oh he's so important you're not
important and you know what
i am though i am important he's not
so stupid you're not important he's a
[ __ ]
sociopath and he's one of those
sociopaths that's so sociopathic
that he can't even hide his sociopathy
like it's bizarre like most of them are
usually pretty good at
at least uh emulating other people right
but he just doesn't give a [ __ ]
rob says step six build the shack out in
the woods and live in it step seven
learn how to make mail bombs
he but this dude is really just like
yeah man like [ __ ] what do you need
all these people
in your life for oh look at me i called
my mother on her birthday
yeah that's what normal people do if you
deleted all your contacts
probably like three or four people would
even notice that you stopped messaging
them
because you have no friends
you're not like me i'm famous you don't
have friends
david the more you talk about your life
the sadder i am for you and and
i don't live like the coolest life or
anything but
even i'm sad for you the truth is
most of us have about half a dozen
people in our life
that matter i this is a clear case at
least from what i'm seeing it like looks
like somebody that is
putting their loneliness onto everybody
else like like because he's this way
right
everybody in the world probably only has
half a dozen people that they care about
or talk to
everyone else really doesn't and guess
what if you really are trying to find
how to contact somebody
you'll figure it out yeah in my contact
list
that's how i'll figure it out
okay now why am i saying that you should
delete your contact
because you you you're [ __ ]
maybe that or because you're
compensating for something else
or because you just realized that being
a pickup artist isn't gonna last because
now it looks like your hairline's
starting to go my way buddy
and it's it's a lot a little a little
more difficult when you can't
when you start losing that hair and you
don't have that look so when you start
realizing that bitcoin just crashed
today
it's not gonna be [ __ ] it's fine it's
not as fun
dave yeah buddy i mean you gotta
look man it's you gotta you gotta start
learning new tricks buddy mm-hmm because
like roy said when the when the gut
starts getting a little bigger owen and
the gray starts coming into your beard
you gotta be interesting buddy you gotta
have a couple bucks
you gotta be able to pick up the tab and
you got to be able to make these [ __ ]
laugh
and you're not going to be able to to
make these women laugh
because they you don't even understand
each other and you've spent how many
years now abroad
and you've never bothered to learn any
foreign language or learn any new skill
set or learn honestly even just like
like i know people who are boring and
predictable and
are not very exciting who have at least
learned or memorized a couple of amusing
anecdotes or or a couple of funny jokes
out of a joke book
something so that they have a little
pizzazz in there but you've you've
wasted how many years buddy
how many years have you wasted you're
gonna develop absolutely zero
personality
and then you're just going to be an old
fat guy well they say we want about us
but we're old fat guys with personality
well that's why like bald and bankrupt
you give him this much like when he goes
out there and he's
he'll speak russian he'll speak spanish
like he'll he'll actually put
effort into trying like oh i don't know
that i want to learn
i want to learn how to say this word i
want to learn how to communicate
i want to and he's interesting yeah you
know he's a shady globalist spook but i
love baltimore
i love his video and yeah he's a guy you
could see a guy like that
pulling chicks because you'd be like oh
yeah that guy's he's upbeat
he's got a couple bucks on him he could
tell a good story and you know he'd be
like that guy's probably gonna pull some
but like david when you're bold and
bankrupt's age have zero personality
dude
max here is why you should do this it is
so unbelievably important why tell me
why
number one every time that you sign up
for an app
that asks permission to access your
contacts
that app is likely telegraphing
information
about who you are to other people okay
when you sign up for snapchat the first
thing it says is hello we want to have
access
i i just don't sign up for snapchat yeah
i don't have snapchat i'm not a
[ __ ] stripper really the only reason
i have one
thing they get your contact list and
then boom every girl
in the world who you've ever met and you
saved her phone number in your phone
gets a little alert that but you notice
something about him this video is
supposed to be about being anonymous and
everything goes back to girls remember
the video we had of him like he says how
to pick up girls on tinder and he had
like remember we saw the video he had
like 10 phones
like burner phones all with tinder like
picking stuff like everything he does is
very
weird and creepy to me like it's it's
just
it's just something off about him
outside of the fact that he looks like
brendan dilly here
besides that like there's something
about him that just it's just
well the whole thing is just creepy it's
he's almost a person
it's it's it's very creepy everything's
a system it's
like have you thought about maybe just
sitting down and going hey what are you
drinking
if you ever tried that once in your life
david
where you just sat down next to a girl
and went hey what are you drinking
yeah i'll have a jameson you know get
her whatever she wants
and then david what are you doing here
that's all that's all you got to do dave
signed up for snapchat and this also
happens the other way around where
when girls sign up for apps it's it's
kind of funny because oh
my telegram is the one that pops up the
most it'll say so and so sign up for
telegram and i'm like dude
why now there's a few ways dude
dude dude is he putting oh my god
oh my god is he putting all their by the
way just so you guys know
those watching us now can't see the
phone number because you know the way i
have the screen cropped
so we're okay on our end because it's
boxing all these people in his phone
okay so the way the screen's cropped on
our screen you can't see it but in the
full video
he has all of these women's phone
numbers
all of them all of them he has no
like he really just has no consideration
for
anyone else he's making a video about
being anonymous and he doxed every woman
in his phone
and they're all they are they're all all
the numbers start with a very
specific country code and they all have
very specific look to them
he has a he has a type if you will
dude he put every
every woman
you honestly could you imagine if this
was your son
14 14 women's phone number on the screen
could you imagine
if you were like a middle class white
guy
and you have this regular life and you
live in the suburbs and you work hard
and you raise your son
and this is your son now
i mean
let's see uh let's see what i'm trying
to see because the majority of the
country codes
are five two yeah country code five
two okay
five two is mexico
but these are all mexican women
that he has up there
i wonder if these women know that you're
putting all of their phone numbers on
the
[ __ ] internet you god and you know
what the 505 is
nicaragua what is 63
i'm just curious where these women are
from because he spoke to the 6-3 very
recently
philippines okay why do all these guys
present themselves as these [ __ ]
studs
but like whenever you see like the women
there with
you when you go out looking for women
why are you always
seeking out places where women are at an
immediate
and severe economic disadvantage
right oh of course like why yeah but
always always always always always
i would never you know what i mean like
i i wouldn't be able to feel good about
myself like don't get me wrong
if i were in like mexico or i was in
like the philippines
and i saw a hot hooker i wouldn't be
above [ __ ] some hooker in some
foreign country
but like i certainly wouldn't go around
later with my chest puffed out like i
got laid
like you know what i mean like oh yeah
dude i got so much [ __ ] when i was in
nicaragua
you're like yeah those women are
starving
you put all of their food yeah you just
put all their numbers out [ __ ] my god
is that you can delete your contacts and
it's not as simple as just going to
contacts
and then clicking select all and
deleting yeah the other reason you want
to delete your contacts is because some
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the internet is going
to put it on his youtube channel
that's probably another reason what a
piece of [ __ ] i know
like even for him that was that was next
level piece of [ __ ]
you even have to someone has a good
point someone says he's just doing that
to show how many girls are in his phone
because he's still a 16 year old kid to
log into your
cool account women that are from a very
oh my god he's doing it again
ah
what are you doing bro sorry i didn't
know not you
dude what the [ __ ] man
and this video is about being anonymous
well
about like us and him being anonymous
not these [ __ ]
not these [ __ ] eventually you'll come
across a menu where you can
look at your contacts and you'll be
shocked to find out that
many of the contacts that you had no
intention of saving
are actually saved in your google
account
your google account connects with gmail
and gmail oh thank you for that
i didn't know that i didn't know google
had all my information really you
[ __ ] [ __ ] are you kidding me i
know google has a creepy amount of
information on me
i thought i lost my phone when i first
bought it and i was able to find you
one of the fans was able to show me i
could go right on [ __ ] line
and it told me down to a [ __ ] 20-foot
radius where my phone was
and i was like oh it's in my apartment
okay fine but yeah we know david we know
it all
they know everything about us what a
piece of garbage
i hate him